let's talk session right which is my
style and beyond regularity inheritance
will see the round to the wraps yeah
thank you very much thank you to the
organizers for inviting me to the other
end of the program and s someone else it
before today I'm not really identifying
as a pseudo-random analyst with how are
you sayin and put my courses and they
dragged me into it so this is joint work
with people from LSP thief and NVIDIA
back here and Joe spoken tools am I here
so M yes so I'm going to start with
talking about rigolette
just gonna have more slide miss jamba ah
man was hideous no man no it's a
backward party yeah okay i just tried to
do this so i was i was also hoping that
you will live with introducer the levity
psalm and now i have to do so i'm going
to start with this is i'm sure you've
seen it somewhere before regularity
lemma to my ad which he used to prove
the similarity serum asthmatic
progression I'm so the picture is
something like this or like a statement
of this every graph has a partition into
a part of almost equal size so that
would be plus minus one and you have a
lot of control on the edges between the
parts so and the control is its absolute
on regular I'll tell you in a second
what that exactly means and I should
also tell you you have the control only
in almost all the pairs and also her
bound on the number of partitions I of
classes that you will have and this is
bounded it doesn't depend on the graph
only depends on the epsilon so he will
that abound that for any epsilon it work
for any graph that you have
so so what does this mean I am I also
you know you know about the edges that
are inside these classes that are very
few and those that are not in regular
pairs are also very few so you're not
these are something of all the epsilon n
square which is really small portion so
what does it exactly mean this
regularity so a pair is regular if for
suppers of sufficiently large size so
epsilon portion at least on either phone
on either side the density doesn't
differ much from the density of the
original pair so the density is a number
of edges that you have divided by the
number of possible engines right so I
could write this also nightly density
between this pair and the density of the
original path so that's what you have
and and that is a regularity lemma and
then you have some property so one very
important properties always comes up
this is slicing there are slicing lemma
says sub pairs of regular pets inherit
regularity so that means if I have an
apt on regular pair and some sub pair
with you sort of large enough then this
pagan is regular with some epsilon Prime
that depends on on the epsilon and how
large maybe this other parents so the
picture is something like this this is
my original pair and then I have a sub
there sufficient size and then I would
have almost same density also so you can
say it make it a bit more precise but if
you haven't seen this and it doesn't
matter you don't have to believe me what
I said so and so that is something that
you can call it like regularity
inheritance now you have another
property as important as a degree
property and which says that almost
every vertex and has like the degree
that you would spend if it was a random
pair or you could say it has the average
degree almost every vertex on one side
will have the expected degree into the
self and that also works or the sub
pairs because you have this inheritance
for subpath so probably might have seen
look before so and so I also said
there's a counting no I don't know if I
said it but this regularity method often
what you use is you have a user regular
dilemma and counting humor together so
counting them or what does it say say
you have a graph age and you have a big
graph G which has for each vertex of age
it has a large class of that decision
everywhere where there was an edge in
age you have an epson regular pair
actually the edges of the natural
epsilon regular pair and then you know
um that you can count the number of
copies of age in this bigger graph G on
the number of labels copies that you
have a canonical copies so I want each
vertex each vertex to go to the class
when he's supposed to go so and the
number that you'll get is is this one up
to some error but which you can make
more to like and then you have to pay
for it with a regularity so and you want
to count all the copies that come up
this way so this number that you get and
if you just want to prove this for a
triangle just to let me convince you of
this number this is the correct number
then if you have a you have the
situation that's that's a black one to
find or you want to estimate a number of
times it occurs here and there is your
your bigger graph G and then you just
take a vertex here you have how many
choices like how many as many virgins
that are as their I'm the set and then
the neighborhoods in the other two set
and they look like this and then you
know if they're large enough that will
inherit this regularity and so you will
find several edges here to complete the
triangle so that means what did you do
this guy had more or less expected
degree if he wasn't exceptional
but those are only few so this degree
should be about the density between the
spare times the size of the other side
so in total you took like you also
looked here at the density in here you
had to see how many edges were there
that must be also like the density times
the size we would come to this number
now if you want to prove this for a
bigger graph well let's do it with this
picture and how are you going to do it
so you could put you could do it like
this you put the first vertex and then
you'll see like according to where where
this guy that you put has neighbors and
you just reduce this cluster to a
smaller set which are just the name
which Islander here but not in this one
because he is just I don't have to put a
neighbor off this other guy so then you
choose a vertex inside there then you
look at his neighbors and the other says
and you choose the vertex and the next
one and you then you have to restrict to
the neighbors and recruiting tactics
here and then you finally have to here
and here you have to go from the
neighborhood of the first guy and then
you have to go into the neighborhood of
the second fight also inside this set
and then you have to go for the last
time so and then you choose the last
vertex so is this way every time I
choose someone it really depended on how
many earlier neighbors have been
embedded already and that made this said
shrink so much so that gives you
basically this form of them so that's
the way you could prove this counting
limo
so now these things work well together
because the regularity lemma will give
you this epsilon regular partition and
then the counting lemma just start from
this partition and can count the copies
of cutoff graph that you will find them
so you can just apply this if you if you
give them some graph G you can just
apply the regularity to him and then
look in this regular ice graph or the
copies of the small graph you want to
find so so how can you apply this so for
instance you can prove something like
this removal lemma which says that every
graph either has a lot of triangles or
we can delete small number of edges and
make the graph triangles and now that a
lot and few that is epsilon and Delta
independent of each other but and that
basically you can prove by taking the
graph you can delete all the edges that
don't take part in the regular pairs and
then if there are no triangles if there
are no like triples of regular pair now
no triangles in the graph and if they
are there now many until at all and you
can do something like property testing
with this so if you just sent with some
purchases and if they induce a triangle
and you can say the graph is far from
being epsilon far from being triangle
free and if they don't then you say it's
triangle the graphs triangle free and
you are you probably you'll give the
right up something like this can for
this it can be interesting but you can
also use it in other ways like you let
this blow of lemma also came up in her
talk so they're in the same situation as
before with accounting lemma you can
look at this graph G and now instead of
embedding counting how many copies of a
very small graph you have you can count
you can just embed one bar that has
almost the same size as above to you but
it must have bounded degree and I must
have sort of I must sort of fit into
this petition have the edges in the
right right place it so it must look
like something like that has the same
structure as this so um so now what
happens in sparse graphs and sparse
graphs so that means graphs with n
vertices and very few edges with you off
n squared so what is the problem a
problem is that and regularity not
doesn't mean anything anymore because if
the density of a pair is really smaller
than the epsilon of the regularity then
you you don't know if you don't know
anything about the pair like saying this
is regular doesn't really doesn't really
tell you anything about how the edges
are distributed and if you have a graph
of density much smaller than this
epsilon overall and basically any
partition is regular so it doesn't
really say anything so this problem has
been fixed and with this path graph
regularity so which goes back to end of
the 19th go half hour and weirder and
they say yeah it's you're not measuring
right you must substitute the density
with something that even got the P
density which is you scale you take the
density as before but you scare now by P
and P is just an appropriate small
number so instead of the density now you
consider the density divided by opinion
that's what caused it NP density and
then there is a spot regularity lemma
and like these people and then they had
another condition this upper uniformity
condition which was not necessary and so
and they say everybody every if you
graph has a vertex partition into almost
equal size set such that almost all pair
are epsilon regular and but now with
this property so taking this into
account and the rest is just the same
like the number of parts is just the
same so
partition would just the same the analog
for this passing so now what does this
mean and this regulator now you have you
just instead of measuring the the dancer
did how the density difference in the
sub hand and the ordinal that you would
just take the difference of the poppy
density and that's that's then he
regular and if the density of the pair p
and so this is what you can do its path
path and does this mean that you also
have a counting number force pasqua and
if then what would it look like because
it's also not so clear this version that
i had men used to coerce or so for
marrying in the sparse class because the
error factors may be too large somehow
not right so how was it again this
counting number we had this formula here
so what would you have to modify for
making a sparse counting lemma so you
would you would have a different
regulate you now would have this new
regular spot regulator notion here you
will take the P densities here instead
of the original densities and then you
would have to multiply here with P to
the number of edges and because in this
way you will have the error term
measured in the final way it would
really depend on the density that you
have that would be the version that you
would want and now the problem is but if
you want to prove it in the sand why
this will not really work because if you
remember this picture something like
this if you'd have a vertex and you look
at its neighborhoods and then the
neighborhoods are just too small so they
will not really inherit the regularity
that is the problem before we in this
first picture of proving the counting
lemma we had this and we said yeah there
must be the edges because this is
something that's large enough and and so
their edges between a to its regular and
now it is because it's just a small so
so then lemmas not true and you can also
do a concrete counter example if you
want and so this is not doesn't work but
still there is some hope so it's not so
common that you don't have you don't
inherit regularity in a sub pair so it's
with a high probability you do inherit
it if you take a random soft pad so you
know the pictures look there and um so
in random graphs for instance you can
have counting levels so if you're in a
sub graph of a random graph so that was
just okay our conjecture and then you do
have counting lemmas and you can have
similar counting the money went ahead on
the sides before and if you have another
underlying structure then we absurd a
random graph and you can also have it so
that were there was work by Hollywood
shuffle spoken for triangles and then
going on Fox and Zhao and paper where
they show em accounting lemmas for
general graphs age and so in our work we
are and we are we we have counting
numbers that are sometimes better it
depends on the graphic so this goes via
inheritance Lamar's so the the plan
would be that you first proven
inheritance lemon and you can prove
accounting them with ambien at islamic
em used for other things as well so with
pure random now I mean this condition so
there is this conditional by jumbled
nests so you have to basically I'm just
talking about I'm just going to want to
talk about pair so I'm going to talk
about what happens between
w so we'll say it's P gamma by jumble if
every sub pair with the edges between
supper bass sound so in this is the
explanation for this is that this would
it was randomly like a pair like a
random bipartite graph then this would
be the expectation that you would have
for the edges and and the variance would
be something of this of this kind so
you're sort of measuring how far in the
variance how many times the variance
away from the expectation so it's not
like doesn't come from nowhere so in it
yeah and it doesn't so it goes back to
the 80s and also maybe under this name
of jumbled and not by jumbled where they
look at all the pairs not only disjoint
paths but it's not much of a difference
in the end it's all very similar so and
for instance you have that the random
graph is is jumbled so the random graph
yet miss probe edge probability P is
this jumbled and this is essentially
best possible because you can't be like
really you're better jumbled if this
number is smaller right so you cannot be
much better than the random graph which
shouldn't make sense and then there are
several examples like this n D lambda
graph and you can have explicit
constructions for by jumbled graph so
now the plan would be you have the
pseudo random graph gamma and the sub
graph G and then you prove an
inheritance lemma for that
regularity in the graph G is going to be
inherited in the sub path and then you
can use this to show County and OMG and
so in the inherent is to overcome this
problem that we have so the lemma that
we have and
I'm going to compare this then with kali
hawk owl em ahead first such a lemon
very similar them so what we have is
this so we are starting in this
situation where we we are looking at a
triple and we have by drum bonus between
these two x and y & x jumbo nest between
winder and that and that is in the
underlying by jumbled crap bummer and
then in g we have regularity here so now
i'm sorry this is slightly different
from my definition before so this tells
you something about the density that so
and this is what we have and never mind
not what exactly is saying it just says
this is these two are like by jumbled
and G this is epsilon regular and then
you know that in this picture so a
neighborhood of a vertex and together
with the whole other set Z is going to
inherit the regularity of this pair so
you'll have another epsilon this epsilon
prime but it's just like before I mean
this would depend some of that knowledge
so and the other one wrong and then you
have this two-sided lemma where you in
the end you will have you look on both
sides into the neighborhood of this
vertex ax
and then you need just more one more
drum but in this condition here so
that's what is what our lemons see and
if i compare with these venom of these
people and they have basically we only
they have this number here and they have
a p2 the five half so it's a bit in the
other lemma we have this number they
have for you can argue this more
beautiful but ours is smaller so let's
and what can you do with it so you can
do the counting limit which is sort of
noah base to talk on many motivations
the counting lemma so we have counting
mammals which happen on boxes are also
had but I what I like different and yes
and sometimes they're better so i said
this depends on the club so we have this
so now we have two counting animals and
they're called one-sided and two-sided
but it's different one side and two side
before there's one side and two side
watch for the inheritance was to say if
i look at the neighborhood just on one
side and the other side is the whole set
or if i look on they go to both sides
but now this counting them are just tell
me this bound here and talk about the
numbers of copies of some graphic is at
least something so that's just something
different
so so we have this this is just what we
wanted I mean it's just one side but the
rest of this is just what I had before
in this county level that we would like
and the conditions are that you have the
regularity and you have the underlying
by jumbled mess in this in this
partition oh yeah so no yeah it's it's
not clear what this is that's some
parameter of the bluff age that has to
do with when you're in animation of the
vertices of edge you look at how many
edges they send backwards somehow so
yeah I think I can't explain it
so in this lemma is seems to be always
at liters least as good as the lemma
they have and for some graph it's better
and then we have a two-sided counting
lemon and now we have so now we can we
have like we can estimate it both sides
of its meters plus minus gamma and we
have the by jumbo nice condition now is
this one here so there is not only this
parameter p reg there's also this and
each other which is something between
the maximum degree of edge and the
maximum last degeneracy or so yeah it's
there is a definition for this detail
which also would like not to tell you
and em but it yeah something between
these two so um yeah so that's legit and
that's for some grass better so what
else can you do with it so you can we
have this then these people shall have
some blow up lemon for spark lab so the
blow-up lemma I had this picture in the
beginning until you remember that's what
that was and they use this they use the
inheritance lemma for this here so it's
not only useful for the counting Lamar's
and they also use this blow up a lemma
for proving a bandwidth serum for sparse
graph recently so that there are more
applications that you could have
so just quickly a bit of an idea how
this how this proof worked for one side
one sided inheritance which was well in
this picture here we have this by
jumbled mess this regularity and then
you inherit this regularity in this pair
so so you would first classify the pair
so this so you take pairs of two
vertices in Y so here and you look at
what their neighborhood so we'll be here
and what their neighborhood in that
their joint neighborhood in that looks
like so that can be like if I'm looking
at it in G so I will just say it's
typical if it's as expected more like
I've expected or less in G or it could
be larger or it could be really not then
it would be even if i look at it in the
most by jumbled underlying by jumbled
graph than it is large so that would be
really exceptional so those really won't
happen so much that I can just ignore
them so and then I will classify
purchase from here as bad if this pair
so that's knowing in gamma so I should
have drawn it may be in yellow if if
this pair I mean no this is should be
good but if this pair is to dance or if
it's irregular so and then you can count
and can say that then in this pair you
have many more copies of seesaw than
expected and then you can say the
average care has more common neighbors
than you would have expected and that's
both in G so that's all of this mg and
then you can say yeah then you must have
many bad pests in this neighborhood so
you could say if you can say if a vertex
is bad then you have many bed pairs and
neighborhood in his neighborhood in why
but on the other hand from the
regularity of y&z you know that there
are not so many copies of c-4 so against
of the c-4 car and you know that there
are a few bad pets overall and why so
then there must be few triples x y y
prime of it YY prime are bad and then
there are few bad eggs and then you know
what if you have few wear this pair is
too dense and you also have few words
too fast so then you just show that a
few where this path to dance or regular
so now you know that you where they are
not behaving well so you must have that
most regular and corporate entity so
it's like very rough oh yes so and the
proof of the two side it is similar but
of course you have to do something
different with the other any questions
from speaker matches so disregard
dr. fector in a minor so that may be in
the two random setting little bit
surprising so that I mean the random
said knowing is natural that would
sometimes have some Loctite loss but in
the running selling sees it so is there
any indication or how it comes out in
the
yes I think they'd look
but it shouldn't be there were no you
estimate some sizes and need to
partition with this neighborhood and you
sum it up and lock comes
any further questions Jacob so one of
the things that we couldn't figure out
because it's very hard in the other
direction to see what's tight and what's
not tight one of the problems is we
don't have good constructions of pseudo
random graphs that are each free or
maybe have smaller account and I'm just
wondering if there was anything
interesting to say about this because it
was kind of something that we were at a
loss there's like examples like noga
loans graph of a pseudo-random triangle
free graph and that's the wrong exponent
compared to the upper bound here and I
think for the case of triangles and for
clicks we didn't know what the right
I don't know no but seems to be some
controversy about what should be the
right thing for triangle right yeah
sorry thing a very interesting I think
you believe in robust concert I think
sorry you believe every believe in no
guys construct but the bounds are tiny
imagine a pseudo-random miss Laurie and
I think you you didn't believe it so we
thought hard about this for it's been a
while
more questions okay normal questions
that's like a speaker again
[Applause]